[Music]
hello good afternoon I'm super excited
to be here and today we're gonna be
talking about constraint layout with a
focus heavily on the visual editor how
to use the visual editor to effectively
make constraints in Android studio so
I'm gonna start out by talking about the
basics and then oh I'm Chris UX designer
on Android studio and I'll be talking
about some of the new features we've
added to Android studio for constraint
layout awesome awesome and I'm Shawn
McMullen developer advocate for Android
after we talk about the basics the
features that shifting constraint Liat
1.0 1.1 we're gonna talk about some of
the new features that are coming out and
constraint layout 2.0 so let's dive in
what are constraints so when I add a
view to a constraint layout in the
visual editor I'm gonna get these four
new handles one on the Left top right
and bottom if I click one of those or if
I go over to the view inspector over
here and I click that I'm gonna go ahead
and add a constraint to this view so I
want to pause for a second here and
mentioned the in constraint layout
before I added this constraint
constraint it's gonna add that view to
the view hierarchy but it's just gonna
lay it out somewhere on the screen so
I'm gonna have that constraint it's 30
DP off the top and if I had another one
to the left
I've now fully constrained this view now
constraint layout knows how to solve
where this view goes we're gonna see
starting with this very simple example
how to kind of build up more complex
examples of constraints and of course I
could change this 30 DP margin to be 50
DP or it could set both of them to 0 DP
and then add a constraint over on the
right side if I do that I'm actually
going to Center this view if I add
another constraints on the bottom I'm
gonna Center this view on the entire
constraint layout and this trick of
constraining equally on the right on the
left is going to work everywhere and
constrain it this is how you Center a
view inside or on top of another view so
let's take a look at one more thing I
can do with just a single element using
constraint layout so if I look at this
slider that's over on the left it starts
at 51 I've constrained the top and the
bottom like this and I can change that I
can change it up to 25 and when I do
that instead of centering it exactly
it's going to introduce a bias it's the
later its going to introduce a bias to
the layout now it's gonna lay that out
25% along the way
75% along the way and of course there's
of course a horizontal slider as well so
let's dive even further into this view
inspector and taking a look at what's
available in the visual editor so
there's this triple chef going on here
inside of this view inspector and I
asked John Hufford about this and he
said that's because it's wrapped content
so it's like trying to pull in as hard
as it can from both sides so this is
what it's going to show for rap content
I can change that of course to fix width
that's 100 DP that's not too exciting I
can also change that to match
constraints so match constraints is a
new feature for constraint let it's a
new way to layout views and what it says
is take up all of the views all of the
space available by the constraints given
so in this case I'm constrained off the
right on the left so it's basically the
same thing as full parent and this is
how you would take up the full screen in
constraint layout you wouldn't want to
use fill parent and constraint layout
and when I'm in match constraints I get
this really interesting icon here and I
originally thought this was a heartbeat
for the longest time I thought this was
like a heartbeat icon
I asked John about this it turns out
that's actually a spring and on some
versions of Android studios you get two
Springs on some versions you get one so
I guess it's more springy for some of us
than others
so let's switches back over to wrap
content and let's add another view so we
can start building more complex layouts
so I'm just gonna add an image view then
I'm gonna constrain it so it's you know
20 DP
off of this text view then I'm gonna
constrain it on the right and it does
you know what we'd expect right it's
gonna go ahead and move that image view
so it's 20 DP off the left and the ends
are aligned now I'm going to add another
constraint over on the right and we'll
see that this image view is gonna Center
itself as here we can see the centering
trick that we did for the whole screen
we can do this on another view as well
now I want to change the width of this
view from wrap content to match
constraints and this time instead of
match constraints meaning it's going to
take the whole screen it's gonna take
the width of this text view whatever
size that text view is this image user
I'm gonna try to match that constraints
as well and when I do that this new
control shows up in the visual editor so
this little Y
it creates a little triangle I'm gonna
click it actually enable an aspect ratio
on this image view and this is this is a
really nice feature if you want to
display an image with an aspect ratio
images you know when we get them from
designers are from the web they come in
whatever aspect ratio and our designer
always wants them to be one by one or
two by one or sixteen by nine you're
laughing because you're a designer and
it's my fault sorry and so we can set up
exactly what our designers asked for
we'd have to write a lot of code to do
the resizing or to fix this aspect ratio
and also resize this view as that text
view changes at the same time
well maintaining this aspect ratio now
if I set this aspect ratio to 3 to 1 I
kind of introduce these conflicting
constraints here I've set 1 aspect ratio
that says I'd like this to be 3 to 1
aspect ratio or 1 constraint 3 to 1
aspect ratio and then another constraint
saying this can be no wider than this
text box it's good its constraint light
has to solve both of these at the same
time and it's gonna choose to use the
constraints from the text box above the
aspect ratio I can free up another
dimension for constraint layout to solve
so if I change the height to be matched
constraints it's capable of resizing
both dimensions so now it can set the 3
to one aspect ratio by making this image
view less tall so that's all we can do
with just a single you know element or
two elements let's add a little bit more
of a complex view and talk about how to
lay things out with more features from
constraint layout
so my designer just sent me this lovely
email form thank you
and so I want to pause for a second I
mentioned this is a talk about
constraint layout this is not a talk
about how to design login forms I did
one of those earlier today please don't
copy this login form there's many
problems but we can see here there's a
couple things going on the labels are
right aligned to some sort of invisible
line in the center of the screen the
edit text appeared to be left aligned to
that same line and then the login a new
account button are kind of hanging off
and there appear to be aligned to the
you know edit text right and then at the
same time email and password appear to
be vertically centered on the screen
we're gonna try to do all of those
things in constraint layout so before we
do that how are we gonna lay out those
you know text views right we have the
email texting
Mel edittext we could align like the top
of the text you to the top of the text
or the bottom of the text feeder the
bottom of the edit text that would
actually be incorrect if we take a look
at how fonts work just dive into fonts
for a second and look at font metrics we
have a bunch of them we have this base
line at the bottom which in English in
most languages almost everything sits on
then at the very top we have the
ascender line which nothing goes above
and then out at the bottom that dashed
line is the descender line and it turns
out that the metric that really matters
is this base line and if we land out two
texts that have completely different
fonts next to each other along the base
line that creates a single line of text
for our eyes and it allows us to read it
as a coherent unit so we want to do that
in constraint layout so if I select this
email label I'm gonna get this
controlling constraint layout it looks
like this I've been enlarged it
substantially so you can see it when I
click it I get my favorite control in
all of Android studio
it actually blinks in the editor and I
call it the green glowing orb of
baseline so we can go over to the edit
text and click that same thing and now
we can drag from one constraint or sorry
one base line to the other and create a
constraint saying these text views
should have the same baseline and we'll
do that for all of the other text views
on the screen here in order to set up
all the baseline alignments and when you
line up text next to text you almost
always want to use the baseline that's
the correct way to do it all the time
especially in constraints layout so now
let's go ahead and put that login button
on the screen as well so the login
button has to be constrained off this
edit text and then it's also going to
get constrained on the right side this
figure out how to do this centering
write the email and password is
vertically centered on the screen how am
I gonna do that
so we've been doing this thing where we
put a constraint on both sides of a view
and it's Center so let's try to do that
so I'm gonna put them straight from
email up to the top of the screen it's
gonna pull stuff up to the top from
password down to the bottom of the
screen and it's gonna pull stuff down to
the bottom and so far this makes sense
now I guess I'm gonna have to add a
constraint from password to email right
because I want these things to go back
together so I'm gonna do that and this
is actually gonna Center password
between email on the bottom of the
screen which is not quite what I wanted
let's pull email back down with another
constraint and when I do that I'm
actually going to
solve this problem like a little bit
differently than how I did before this
introduces what's called a chain and
constraint lad and it's gonna solve it
with the chain solver
now of course setting up all of those
constraints by hand individual editor is
kind of tedious so there's a helper for
this you can go into right click on
center and choose vertically when I have
email and password selected and when I
do that it's going to set up all of the
constraints that I just talked about so
inside of a chain there's actually three
different ways that can get laid out for
technically the three that I use all the
time so we have spread which means
evenly distribute everything so this
looks similar to what we did with linear
layout we have spread inside which is
basically the same thing except the
first and the last elements get pushed
to the edges and then the one I used
most of the time is packed so this says
push everything towards the center of
the screen and center it as a group and
so that's what we're going to use here
right we're going to use a packed chain
in order to Center both of these views
together so there's one more thing we
need to do right we need to put this
invisible line in the middle of the
screen but everything's kind of based
around so to do that I'm gonna go to
helpers I'm gonna add a vertical
guideline so a vertical guideline is
basically you can think of it as a new
edge of the screen so it's like I have
one on the left of the screen I have one
on the right screen and now I've put an
edge of the screen in the middle of the
screen that I can use as an anchor for
constraints I'm gonna head and move that
to where I'd like it in my design and
now I could just take those text views
and create constraints from those two
this guideline and the kind of visualize
what this is doing underneath if I move
the guideline it's actually gonna move
the entire layout now so let's move that
back and then let's get another design
because it turned out that design was
not performing very well so after many
user studies we've discovered the
solution to our login form is left
aligning the labels so my job is now at
implement this so let's try to do that
well I did it and I translated its
German and this is what happened this is
not not great so what happened here so
it turns out if I lay this out similar
to the way I just did right so passwords
the longest field in this in these
labels so if I set up a constraint from
the edit text over to password and then
another constraint from the
it takes down to the password edit text
this is gonna work great in English but
then when I translate it to German these
constraints this invariant I had that
password is the longest field isn't no
longer correct so what I'm gonna need is
something that's dynamic that's based on
all of these things it's kind of like a
view group you know basically I might
want like a linear layout to hold these
things but actually I'm in constraint
layout so how do I do that in constraint
layout well it turns out there's another
helper and we're gonna use that now so
we've to go into helpers and we use add
vertical barrier this allows you to add
a barrier to the screen what a barrier
is is it's kind of like a view proof in
text it's actually called a grouping
code so we can open up the component
tree select our email and password and
drag that down to be inside of our
barrier now it's not actually a view
group it's just a view that's added to
the screen it's positioned on one side
or the other of all of the views that
are inside of it right by default it's
on the left but if I open up the
attributes pain and scroll down to the
bottom I'm going to find a barrier
direction which I can set to the end and
now that I've done that I'm going to set
up my constraints and then translate my
English over to German and everything's
gonna relay out and do exactly what I
expected so that's really it that's all
of the features and constraint lay out
1.0 and constraint lay out 1.1 so now
I'm gonna pass it over to Chris who's
going to talk more about more tricks
that can be used to use the visual
editor to build constraints cool thanks
Sean so with constraint layout we've you
know over time introduced many concepts
and so you know we started with the
basics which is just constraints margins
baselines and chains but over 1.1 and
2.0 alpha we've introduced things like
guidelines and barriers and groups and
then there's many more helpers to come
and then of course there's motion layout
but one thing that we've heard
consistently is that as we've added more
concepts and the layouts have become
more complex
it's actually become increasingly harder
to manage all of these with constraint
layout and so what I'm here to tell you
today is that we've actually been
improving a lot of this in the visual
editor in the Android studio and so the
four areas I'll talk about
are creating constraints and how we
improve that also some new view options
we added to the design surface and then
some tricks around zooming and panning
which are super useful when you're
dealing with constraint layout and then
of course using sample data which we
introduced back in the 3/2
so creating constraints so you know in
this case we have two components it's
pretty simple we have an image view in a
text view and so if we want to Center
the image view then we just put one
constraint on the top and one on the
bottom but let's take that lovely login
form from before so from a UI
perspective this is actually not too
complicated we just have some labels we
have some inputs and we have some
buttons but from the constraint point of
view there's actually a lot going on so
you know we have this guideline in the
middle we have the login button
constrained at the bottom and the right
of the input we have the inputs
themselves constrain to the guideline
and so because all these components are
pretty close to each other you know when
you're dragging these constraints around
in the layout editor it can actually be
pretty challenging to get that get it
right even when I made that slide I hid
half the constraints because it was too
busy yeah that was very simplified so
one thing we've done is actually is
we've added the ability to add
constraints directly with the context
menu so in this case you know if you
have components that are really close to
each other this makes it a lot more
precise and more direct to actually set
those constraints so in this case and
this is available in 3 3 beta as well so
you can try it out today and so in this
case if we select one component which we
have this a lovely cat picture you can
just simply constrain it to the parent
so what does it look like if you have
multiple multiple components so in this
case we have these two text views that
are really close to each other and so
I'm not sure if people have tried to
create constraints between two text
views that almost overlap it becomes a
little painful when you're going from
the bottom of one to the top of the
other and so with this new context menu
you can actually just keep the two
selected and then when you open them the
context menu there's now this
constrained menu and so you can actually
just see that the two elements that you
want to use are there and then you can
easily cascade
to the right constraint that you want
and in this case you know we only have
we're only showing the start and end and
that's because in this case the top and
bottom constraints have already been set
so we don't show them so we can look at
another example so here we want to
constrain the location icon to this
vertical guideline that's all the way on
the left so if you use the drag-and-drop
method what you'll notice is that as you
drag from the left or sorry from the
right all the way to the left you get
all these
I guess Sean's favorite little green
flashing stuff a lot of these targets
that all show up when you try to create
the constraint and so if you're trying
to target some of these smaller things
like the following text or the numbers
it actually gets pretty hard when you're
trying to do drag and drop with
constraint layout and so again this
makes it a lot more direct so you can
select the guideline and the icon and
just use the context menu and if you
really don't want to select these things
on the design service you can totally
use the component tree this is becomes
even more useful depending on how deep
or how complex your hierarchies get and
does the exact same thing but if you do
like drag and drop you know you can
still do it and one thing that we've
tried to make easier is actually when
you drag it and so in this case we have
this new gesture which pending is called
drag to Center and so I think as I
mentioned before as you drag you now see
all these like little targets and so
instead of trying to actually target
those specific green dots you can just
simply drag to the middle of the thing
that you want actually constrain to and
so in this case this is just some
screenshots if I drag from the mountain
view text view I can just drag all the
way to the middle of the cat picture
release the mouse and then I get this
nice pop-up menu that just shows me the
two constraints that I can set and so in
this case because the mountain view
we're going from the left of the
mountain view text view to the cat
picture the two constraints that make
sense are actually the left and the
right or start and end and we actually
have this as well which comes in handy
when you have overlapping views and so
this one's pretty simple but sometimes
you know you have views that you want to
hide and show it run
and so all you have to do is drag to
wherever you to the target and what
we'll do is actually figure out what
fuse are under that pixel that you
released the mouse and then show you a
context menu accordingly so if we move
on to view options so the design surface
has always had a bunch of view options
to meet to take advantage of when you're
working with your layouts so the two
I'll talk about specifically are which
we added is show all constraints and
live rendering so if we go back to our
login form gonna reuse this a lot you
know the constraints are set here but
the thing is you know when you're trying
to like let's say you're new to this
layout and you're trying to actually
edit constraints on one of these
controls there's actually a lot going on
and actually again this is pretty
simplified compared to the normal design
surface and so what we've done in
Android studio 3.3 is we've added this
option to show all constraints but it's
actually turned off by default and so
here's a quick video to show you what
that looks like and so what we'll do
instead is we only show the constraints
on the actively selected component so
this makes it easier to just you know
work with the component that you're
actually working with and not be
distracted by all the arrows and margins
that usually come with the layout of
course you can easily turn this back on
if you do want to see all the
constraints at the same time and so this
is kind of showing you a side-by-side
and so on the left we have it turned off
and on the right we have it turned on
and so especially in the design surface
or design mode it actually cleans it up
a lot because you don't have all these
little arrows and margins especially for
elements that are really close to each
other like the 3:22 and following and
the 20 followers and then in blueprint
mode it's the same thing
even though blueprint mode is heavily
simplified because we don't render the
components it still gets a little hairy
to look at and so we think this is a
good option as well here the other view
option we have is live rendering so
we've actually done live rendering by
default in constraint layout for quite
some time
go back can I go back and so it's on by
default but depending on the specs of
your machine in AK it can actually be a
little slow so as you drag around you
might you know make a mistake or
oftentimes when I've tried to use it
it's I'll try to create a constraint and
then the button will move way after I
drag it and so that actually causes me
to make more mistakes and so and so if
you turn it off it's actually much
faster as you drag and move things
around you can still see the bounding
boxes when you're dragging around and so
you'll know where things end up the only
downside is that it just doesn't render
as you drag and alternatively you can
use blueprint mode so here we don't do
any live rendering we usually recommend
this is the best way to work with
constraint layout because you can just
focus on the constraints and so you know
as a refresher to set these options
there in the top left corner under the
eyeball and if you want to switch
between design and blueprint mode that's
using the blue layers icon as well so
the other thing I'll talk about zooming
and panning so you've actually been able
to zoom in pan in the layout editor for
a while now and it comes really in handy
when you're dealing with constraint
layouts especially when again when
things are really small or when they're
really close to each other overlapping
well what we've done in 3/3 is we've
actually changed the keyboard shortcuts
to match more of what we expect from the
design tools like Photoshop and sketch
and so to zoom in you can use commander
control depending on what OS you're on
and then the equals sign so you don't
have to actually hit shift and then the
equals sign to get the plus just hit
equals but if you really want to shift
it actually still works and then with
the mouse wheel you can use you can hold
commander control and scroll up and then
if you have a trackpad you can just
pinch in to zoom then the opposite is
for zoom out so it's command control -
and then command and control with the
mouse wheel scroll down and then pinch
in the opposite direction and then zoom
to fit so if you're zoomed in and you
want to get back to that layout where
you can see the whole thing you
just use command and control plus zero
and so then if you're zoomed in and you
don't actually want to zoom out but you
want to pan around you can actually do
so by holding space and then using the
mouse to kind of click and drag and this
is kind of a familiar gesture if you've
used Photoshop or other design tools and
so the last tip I'll talk about is using
sample data and so a sample data in
constraint layout it's actually easier
to preview how your layouts will respond
to different content types at runtime
and so we actually introduced sample
data helpers in the Android studio 3 to
to make it easier to work with in the
design surface specifically for image
views text views and recycler views but
before that you could use tools
attributes in XML which are still useful
but we just didn't find where as
discoverable on the design surface and
so with the image view we have two
sample sets we have avatars and we have
scenic backgrounds and so if you and if
you want to add your own images to the
sample data you can do so you just
create a sample data directory at the
root of your project and so with sample
data and with your image views
constrained you can actually just you
know quickly switch between different
types of images and then also set
different aspect ratios and constraints
so you can quickly see how your layout
responds without actually having to run
your app and the same goes the text view
so a text view we have a bunch of sample
data so we have cities we have lorem
ipsum we have dates full name and again
if you want your own sample data you can
create it at the sample data directory
at the root of your project and I think
we support flat text files and JSON and
actually with text views I think this is
even more important because oftentimes
you know you'll have text views that are
meant for more open-ended content such
as profile descriptions so in this case
we have you know domestic shorthair is a
very short description but then on the
right this one's just you know a bunch
of text plopped in there and so you know
without having to run out your app you
can see just with sample data how your
layout responds so I don't need to copy
lorem ipsum off the internet every time
now yeah just
and I think as the you mentioned in the
previous example this is great for
testing out across different languages
and so with that I'll hand it back to
Sean to talk about some new features
thanks Chris
all right so that covers everything in
constraint Liat 1.1 1.0 some of the new
features in the design service coming
out in 3.3 they should hopefully help
you use that to build constrained layout
and now I want to move on to new
features coming out at constraint layout
2.0 and by that I mean motion editor the
thing we're all very very excited about
so I want to show of hands like who has
tried playing with motion editor already
so I see five people so hopefully we can
give like a nice introduction here to
the basic concepts of motion editor and
then Chris is gonna go back onstage and
talk again about the design surface so
motion editor is their motion layout
allows you to build dynamic layouts
using all of the features of constraint
layout we talked about earlier but then
just changing the constraints over time
so here we can see an example of
building a collapsible header that Chris
Bane's put together that does a pretty
dramatic animation that would be pretty
hard to build with a collapsible header
itself so you see that that title image
actually hides itself behind the view as
it Scrolls up it's a pretty dramatic
animation so before we get to something
like that let's talk a little bit about
what we can build with motion layout
motion layout can be used to build
collapsible headers you can build state
feedback or transitions maybe the open
and closed state of a drawer and you
could also make most of the animations
that are in this presentation as well to
understand motion to understand
animation in general it's really
important to take a step back and think
about like what actually defines an
animation not not just on Android but
like even if a Disney movie what how do
they make an animation all animations
are defined by a start and an end so I
start over here I'm here and then I'm
ending over here and in between over
time I created an animation by doing
that walking so that's a very complex
motion let's talk about a very simple
one and talk about the same concept I'm
gonna put a blue dot on the screen and
I'd like to build an animation in order
to do that I have to define a start I'm
gonna put it in the top left corner with
constraints I have to define an end I'm
gonna put that in the bottom right
corner with constraints and now in order
to build an animation all I do is
transition from one from the start to
the end over time and that's what motion
layout will do for you it'll figure out
how to transition that blue dot from the
start down to the end to build a motion
layout you have to start with emotion
layout in your XML so motion layout is a
subclass of constraint layout so we did
that so that it would have all of the
features of constraint layout while
adding all of the new features in order
to support animations a motion layout
then points to a motion scene which is a
separate XML file from your main layout
and the motion scene is where you encode
that start and end information that
defines your animation the start and end
are defined in terms of constraints sets
and what are constraints us you may be
familiar with this already but if not
what we've been talking about so far
looks like this right so this is what I
would call a constraint layout it's the
views the actual labels plus all of the
constraints and all the sizing
information a constraint set is just
this part it's just the constraints and
just the sizing information it points to
IDs of actual views but it doesn't
actually contain the views themselves
and if I animate a constraint set it
would look like that and if I apply that
to a real view and did that same
animation it would look like that so
let's build a a fairly you know easy to
follow along animation in constraint
layout with motion layout so here we
have a pretty dramatic reveal animation
where the title comes down to the top
the subtitle expands down below and then
the description comes in from the bottom
and at the same time the image in the
background is also resizing itself so
there's a lot of things going on here
this might be actually hard to write in
code but it's fairly easy to write using
motion layout so let's take a look at
how we're gonna do that so to make a
motion layout I'm just going to add I'm
going to define the start in the end so
the start I'm gonna move that title off
the screen and I'm gonna do that by
making a constraint from the end of the
title to the start of the the viewport
to the constraint layout and constraint
layouts very happy to lay your views out
off the screen if you asked it to
so please intend to do that if you ask
it to then we are also going to do the
same thing on the bottom where we're
gonna put a constraint from that
description text to the bottom of the
screen to push that description start
description text off the screen then to
actually build that we're gonna go ahead
and make a motion layout so again this
is a subclass of constraint layout and
it has one new tag it has this layout
description tag which is going to point
over to that motion scene file here I'm
gonna call it space scene then I have to
define my layout which is just the views
I don't give it widths and Heights I
don't constrain anything I'm literally
just gonna make a list of three text
views in an image view now I'm gonna go
over to that space scene file I was
talking about earlier this is the motion
scene file so it has a motion scene tag
and inside that it defines a transition
and a transition has a start and an end
and again that's the thing that defines
an animation animation always has a
beginning and it always has an end to
define start I'm gonna make a constraint
set and a constraint set is just a tag
it has an ID and then it defines a list
of constraints and it's gonna have to
define a constraint for every single
view that its constraining here I'm just
gonna show one of the views and leave
the others off the slide deck because I
got a little long but will give will say
which idea I'm constraining I'm gonna
constrain the title I'm gonna set its
height width and I'm going to set its
padding and then I'm also going to
constrain to push it off the screen I'm
gonna constrain the end to the start of
parent let me do the same thing for the
constraints that end I'm going to just
go ahead and make the title view
constrain the start to the start of
parent and this brings that title onto
the screen I'm gonna do the same thing
for all of the other views in this
layout as well and that's all I have to
do it's just a little bit of declarative
XML and I've built this animation so now
I'm gonna pass it back to Chris he's
going to talk a little bit more about
the motion editor
so at i/o this year we gave you a sneak
preview of the motion editor when we had
announced motion layout since then we've
been working pretty hard on it but it's
not quite ready yet sorry to say but
we're still very excited about it
but we also wanted to make sure that we
focus on getting some foundational
pieces in place before we release it we
also don't want to be too impatient and
really make sure we get it right
unlike some things we've released too
early in the past like instant run
so the first foundational piece is
really the motion layout library itself
so we just talked about that and it's
been out for a while and so before we
got too far in building the tool we
wanted to make sure that we actually
nailed the right animation concepts and
controls that are required to make these
simple and beautiful animations on top
of that the library also needs to be
performant and integrate well with your
existing views and so John Hufford and
Nicolas have been really working hard on
the library and so they love all your
feedback and all the really cool demos
that have been coming out so please keep
it coming and thank you but the other
thing is actually the quality of Android
studio and so this is the second
foundational piece and it's been the
primary focus for us in three three and
the upcoming three four release and so
in this case we've made a lot of
performance dinner sorry performance and
interaction improvements to the design
surface because it actually has to be
able to render animations at 60 frames
per second and also making it easier to
work with constraints because one of the
biggest prerequisites of motion layout
is you have to know how to use
constraint layout and so we think that
if we invest in the quality now in the
tool it will actually make the motion
editor experience much better in the
future and so with that I'm here to show
you some very early explorations of the
motion editor these are just mock-ups
this is not the build I'm the designer
remember so this is all made in
Photoshop yeah this is all four of
course we'd love to hear your feedback
so feel free to find me or Shana and I
think John is here as well I will be at
the speaker QA to talk more about it
so if we take the example from before
where we have the space picture and we
have some text views animating in let's
just
use that as kind of the context of what
we'll see in the motion editor so what
does that actually look like so here we
have a new perspective on the
componentry which for now we're just
calling the transitions view and so for
the purpose of the talk I'm just going
to talk about this new view because we
think this is the most significant
animation part of the new UI of course
you know later on you'll actually have
the other views like the property panel
and the palette but we we haven't quite
figured out the details of how that
integrates with this timeline or this
transition view so stay tuned for that
so in this case we have the start of the
transition and so you can see that the
text views are actually off the viewport
but you can see that there's a motion
path that goes from without side and
then in we don't actually render the
text views outside the viewport today
but that's definitely something that we
will need to have for animation because
we know that's a very typical animation
example to have things fly-in and so if
we kind of fast-forward through halfway
through the transition so now you can
see that the text views have moved about
half way in and in this case we have the
space image zoom back out and that's
kind of what we intended here so free if
we were wined let's go deeper on what
this transition view actually does so
we're only showing one transition right
now and it's uniquely named by its start
and end constraint set which simply is
just start and end in this case you can
have multiple transitions per motion
layout and so with this drop down you'll
be able to switch between the different
transitions and of course we'll load the
corresponding constraint sets and change
the timelines so you can see how the
components change and so each transition
has its own properties which is of
course the start and the end constraint
set it has the duration which is
expressed in milliseconds and the
stagger property which allows you to
actually stagger the the animation
itself so if we move down we have the
timeline and so you have starting from
the left you have the playback bar so
you can loop the animation as many times
as you want just to get the animation
right you can quickly jump to the start
or the end and if you want to speed down
or sorry to speed up or slow down the
animation we also allow that as well
again just to like tune the animation
perfectly and we have this time control
here so you can actually step through
millisecond by millisecond just to see
how the animation plays out and then for
the timeline itself you know we show
from 0 to 100 100 being the end and so
you can use this slider here to actually
make the timeline bigger or smaller
depending on which part of the
transition you want to focus on and so
if we move down we can actually see all
the components that you can animate in
the motion layout and so in this case
each component will show that they have
a start and an end constraint set which
are required in order to actually
animate anything and so if we look
specifically at the space flash image it
has a key attribute in the middle or a
keyframe which we're actually going to
change the scale type halfway through
the animation and so if we zoom out
those icons on the timeline actually
correspond to the same icons on the
design surface that way you can actually
kind of correlate okay here's my
components that I'm animating and where
they're starting and ending and what are
the actual motion paths and so that's
kind of where we are with the motion
editor we hope to get it out soon but I
can't promise anything and so your next
year yeah sometime in 2019 and that's it
[Applause]
[Music]